the original Exorcist film was
groundbreaking
you're looking at a masterful piece of
filmmaking from 50 years ago I don't
think there's ever been a movie before
that is created such intense frenzy it
was a phenomenon my journey began as a
mother driven by my love for my daughter
I was a teenager I saw it scared the
wits out of me
we wanted to honor the film with this
continuation wherever those girls went
they brought something back with them
you think they've got possessed by the
devil look at it as a franchise where
you can explore you can ask questions if
anything I'm looking to break rules I'm
looking to put my fingerprints in this
material in this world the only thing
that's ever mattered is protecting my
kid
we're certainly doing everything we can
from frame one minute one to make sure
that it is steeped in veracity and
nuance and Humanity
body in the blood Catherine body in the
blood
you have some experience with possession
yes more than that life it's
a fine thought
you can be taken over by a force that's
inside don't be scared we've met before
Mother
[Applause]
I think they will get their money's
worth with this one